nationwide the percent of tests that
come back positive has declined very
significantly last week roughly 38
percent of the tests in New York were
positive this week that number is down
to 28% new cases in New York are down
50% compared to a week ago and
fatalities are down 40% over the same
period in Louisiana the rate a positive
test result of decline from 25% down to
15% in the last seven days alone 18
states now show a decline in a number of
positive tests in the last seven days
over the last 7 days been very very
significant progress half of all
Americans live in states that have now
taken steps to open their economies just
yesterday governors Gavin Newsom
California Tim Walz of Minnesota and
Bill Lee of Tennessee announced
additional plans to restart certain
sectors we asked every American to
maintain vigilance and hygiene social
distancing and voluntary use of face
coverings we're opening our country it's
very exciting to see we have a lot of
talent involved from governor's down to
people that just stand there and help
you with the doors there's been
tremendous talent involved and
tremendous spirit from our country
country is a great place and it's going
to be greater than ever before I really
believe that I think there's going to be
a tremendous upward shift I spoke with
Tim Cook today of Apple and they have a
good sense of the market and he feels
it's going to be a V the V is sharply
upward later on as we actually get it
fully open today I signed the Paycheck
protection program and health care
Enhancement Act providing 320 billion
dollars to keep American workers on the
payroll 30 billion dollars of the
Paycheck protection funds will be
reserved for small financial
institutions including those that serve
minority and distressed communities
extending vital relief to thousands of
African American
hispanic-american small business owners
and their employees the bill also
delivers seventy five billion dollars
for hospitals so badly needed for
hospitals they've taken a very big hit
and medical providers in areas less
affected by the virus hospitals and
doctors should work with their state and
local health officials on ways to safely
resume elective medical treatments and
care under the cares Act we're sending
direct payments to millions of American
workers more than 80 million Americans
have already received their payment
$3,400 for a typical family of four
$3,400 that's great
and you deserve it the cares Act
requires that the federal government
send out a notice of what benefits
Americans are receiving to fulfill the
requirement the Treasury Department is
mailing a letter to me it will include
the amount their economic impact payment
how it will arrived direct deposit check
or prepaid debit card as well as a
message to the nation letting each
American know that we are getting
through this challenge together as one
American family and that's what's been
happening the whole world is watching
this you have 184 countries out there
that have been hit and now it's probably
higher than that but they're all
watching us they're all watching and
they're calling and they respect what
we're doing so much I spoke with the
leaders of numerous countries today
they're asking if we can send them
ventilators and I'm agreeing to do it we
have tremendous capacity now over
capacity of ventilators we're filling up
stockpiles for our states and for
ourselves federal government is over
10,000 ventilators and we could have a
lot more if we wanted to do that but
we're helping Mexico Honduras Indonesia
France we're sending to France we're
sending to Spain was sending to Italy
and we'll probably be sending to Germany
should they need them over the last
three years we built the strongest
economy and the most successful country
the world has ever seen greatest economy
the world has ever seen
nobody's ever done anything like what we
were able to do and we will rebuild that
economy our economy in the
not-too-distant future I really believe
with all that we've learned and all that
we've done we'll be just as strong and
may be stronger than ever before even
stronger than it was just two months ago
some interesting note is that the FDA
approved the first at-home kovat 19 test
kit just got approved and dr. Stephen
were Stephen Stephen Hahn even is going
to say a couple of words about that and
some other things I want to thank
Stephen the FDA has been incredible
they've been approving not only this but
they've been approving many things at a
pace that's never happened before and
they're being very safe about it as
Stephen told me he's told me told me
very strongly but at the same time
they're approving things at record
numbers in a record at a record rate and
it's really been helpful many tests are
going on many vaccine tests and tests of
every different guide and things are
happening just like this event things
are happening very rapidly and I'd like
to have Stephen tell you a little bit
about it thank you very much thank you
thank you mr. president
appreciate the opportunity to tell you
about what's happening at the FDA we
have a team of more than 18,000
employees including 10,000 scientists
doctors pharmacists and nurses and
they've been working around the clock
because as you probably know many of the
medical products that are being used for
the Cova 19 outbreak are in fact
regulated by FDA the staff have been
hard at work
authorizing tests and other medical
products as part of these efforts to
support diagnostic test development
during this global pandemic the
president has asked us and under to
actually cut down as many barriers as we
possibly could to get medical products
into the medical community and we have
done that
of course recognizing the urgency of the
situation I do want to emphasize what
the president said that is that we are
very much paying attention to safety and
with respect to test validity and
reliability of those tests
and I think it's really important to
understand how far we've come in just a
few short months the academic community
which I come from the private sector the
government we've come together to
develop Diagnostics for a completely new
infectious disease and it's really
important we've heard from many test
developers both in academia and in the
manufacturing world this normally takes
years to develop you've heard dr.
Burke's talk about the fact that HIV
tests have taken many many years to
develop this has happened in weeks and
months we've been laser focused on
working with both industry and academia
to actually make this happen
to date under our emergency use
authorization approach we've quickly
reviewed and authorized 63 tests both
diagnostic as well as seer logic that is
the antibody test we've had several
point-of-care tests and that's important
because those can be done emergency room
when a doctor's office etc and much more
convenient for the patient and this week
as the president said we authorized the
first at-home test by a company called
lab core this is a test where under
certain circumstances with the doctor's
supervision a tests can be mailed to a
patient and the patient can perform the
self swab and then mail it back and get
the results after that time all under
the guidance of a licensed physician and
we're not just letting up with the 63
tests we've proved we are working with
more than 400 test developers who are
pursuing authorization for their
diagnosed gnostics under our current
policies and under our regulatory
approach which is quite flexible many
other tests are becoming available we
are we have heard and have reported to
us 220 labs around the country have
begun patient testing using their own
validated tests this has allowed us to
increase significantly tests around the
country I updated you earlier this week
on serologic tests these antibody tests
that are used to detect natural immunity
and the FDA's approach to help make
these tests available well these are
just one part of our larger response
effort they can play a role in helping
move our economy forward
by helping healthcare professionals
identify those who have immunity to the
Cova 19 and just finally when it comes
to therapeutics
we are leaving no stone
unturned in finding treatments for Kovan
19 you do know that we don't have any
approved currently therapeutics for Koba
19 but we are actively involved with
both the academic and the commercial and
private sector to find those 72 trials
of therapeutics are underway in the
United States under FDA oversight and
211 are in the planning stages so we
expect to see more this includes
convalescent plasma as well as antiviral
therapies work continues on vaccines and
two firms have announced that the FDA
has authorized their trials to go
forward one of which we've mentioned
here before and finally in response to
the president's and taskforce requests
we've stood up the coronavirus treatment
acceleration program we are leaving no
stone unturned as I said and we're
working around the clock to develop
these therapeutics for the American
people thank you very much it's just
about an hour ago a subcommittee with
oversight released some findings that
the FDA doesn't have any review of the
antibody tests that are on the market
there are no guidelines to tell which
one should be out there and there's no
way to test their accuracy they're quite
worried that these are junk tests on the
market because they weren't reviewed
before they were approved it's not true
so under our policy we provide a
flexibility what we've told
manufacturers is that in order to market
in the US they have to validate their
tests they have to tell us that they
validated their tests and then in the
package insert they have to let people
know and users labs etc that those tests
were not authorized by FDA we've
authorized for as I mentioned more in
the pipeline and these tests that have
come in without any information to us
but have been self validated as I
mentioned at the podium a couple days
ago we are working with the National
Cancer Institute as well as CDC to
perform our own validation of the tests
that that have been sent to us so we'll
provide as much information as we
possibly can and there is transparency
on our website about those tests and
also the tests that we have authorized
Thank You mr. president
from early in this effort President
Trump is called forth a
whole-of-government response to the
coronavirus epidemic in America and by
that the president made clear when he
asked me to lead the White House
coronavirus task force not merely a hole
of the federal government but a full
partnership with state and local
governments across the country and today
we renewed that with our latest
conference call with governor's all
across America we've met with them today
specifically to speak about the progress
that our governors are making expanding
testing across the country and we were
pleased to hear about the extraordinary
and rapid progress that governors are
making at the at the outset of the call
where we have more than 50 of our
nation's governors we of course had Pete
Gaynor of FEMA report on progress more
than 35,000 National Guard's stood up
five thousand active duty military
deployed in ten states and we were also
pleased to report that FEMA HHS and the
private sector have coordinated the
delivery of shipments to states around
the country including nearly 67 million
n95 masks a hundred and five million
surgical masks surgical gowns shields
gloves more than ten thousand
ventilators and more than 8,000 federal
field medical station beds beyond the
report that we provided to the
governor's we assured them that at at
the president's direction this is one
team one mission and we made it clear to
the governor's that we know we're all in
this together
and the partnership that we have forged
together really begins with mitigation
efforts it moves to making sure our
health care workers have the support
they need but also testing is in the
forefront of all of our minds we're
working working to make it possible for
every governor to access the existing
capacity to enable our states to be able
to reopen responsibly under the phased
approach the
the president unveiled one week ago a
little bit of context you may recall
that one month ago all of the testing
that have been done in America 80,000
Americans have been tested but as of
this morning 5.1 million Americans have
been tested for the coronavirus a quick
reminder to our fellow Americans and
this was something from our scientists
today at the taskforce we reminded
governors of this as well
that as testing increases dramatically
across the country cases will increase
as well but people should not be
discouraged by those numbers we are
looking at very positive trends in
hospitalization in emergency room
entrances and we continue to see as
we've said at this podium every day over
the last several weeks we continue to
see positive progress not just on the
west coast but even where the corona
virus epidemic is most deeply impacted
in areas of Greater New York City area
New Orleans Detroit and elsewhere on our
nearly two-hour phone call today with
those governors we heard of the progress
governor's were making in implementing
the resources that we've been working to
provide them not just the medical
equipment but also as you recall that
map a week ago that showed where all of
the equipment is all across the country
in all 50 states
Governor Cuomo joined us for the call
today he spoke favorably of his meeting
here at the White House mr. president
and his recognition that testing is a
partnership between the federal and
state governments as Governor Cuomo said
today that he understood that the
federal government works with national
manufacturing and supply chain and the
governor's deal with the labs to expand
and implement testing at the state level
Governor Cuomo also explained how he's
using his licensing authority as a
governor to stand up the more than 300
labs that can do coronavirus testing in
the state of New York and we
congratulated him for his leadership in
that or
to other governors to use their
authority similarly in Tennessee
Governor Bill Lee told us that he's
deployed the National Guard to stand up
more than 20 Drive Thru test sites
they're testing 10,000 people a day have
already tested more than 130,000 people
in Tennessee and they expect to surge
another 15,000 people in testing sites
this weekend in Tennessee Massachusetts
is an area were continuing to watch very
closely as cases have not yet stabilized
and governor Charlie Baker after he he
thanked us mr. president for the Army
Corps of Engineers deployment of four
field hospitals he described how they
have rapidly expanded testing all across
Massachusetts we commended him for that
in the beginning of March he said they
had just one testing site in the state
of Massachusetts and now thanks to
governor Charlie Baker's team they have
more than 30 testing sites Minnesota
governor Tim waltz reflected on the call
today about the partnership he's forged
with the Mayo Clinic the University of
Minnesota and state health department
they're actually collaborating to
perform 20,000 molecular tests and
15,000 antibody tests per day and I'm
looking forward to traveling to the Mayo
Clinic in Minnesota on Tuesday of next
week to learn firsthand from the
governor about their efforts across the
state to expand testing Iowa Governor
Kim Reynolds gave us an update mr.
president on her progress she's
literally tripling testing capacity in
her state through a partnership with a
private sector with the University of
Iowa and Iowa State University as she
also launched the the test Iowa dot-com
website which actually creates an access
point for people to fill out a
questionnaire about whether or not their
symptoms or circumstances would justify
a test
she's sit in the first 72 hours a
hundred and fifty thousand people went
to the test site to receive an
assessment and I was now testing 4,500
people a day in their state in Indiana I
spoke also today with governor Eric
Holcomb they've tested 72,000 Hoosiers
to date they're adding drive-thru sites
they'll have ten drive through sites
established by the state of Indiana
for the end of the weekend and as other
governors have done governor Holcomb
last week opened up half of their
elective surgery sites and hospitals
across the state and they'll be opening
up the balance of their elective surgery
sites next week in Maryland another area
that we're watching very closely
governor Larry Hogan expressed
appreciation for federal support as he's
continuing to scale testing he had been
in touch with the National Institute of
Health which is opening up its
laboratories for Maryland to do testing
and we were also able to confirm to him
that Walter Reed hospitals laboratory
capacity is available to Maryland and in
Utah
mr. president governor gary Herbert told
us that he actually diverted 1,200 state
employees to do contact tracing in their
state in the last 36 hours 23,000
residents have also signed up for what
they're calling their healthy together
app and they have 50 different testing
locations across Utah and have tested
82,000 people in the state already other
state examples mr. president we're just
as inspiring governor Phil Murphy of New
Jersey's forged a partnership with
Rutgers University working closely with
the FDA they've authorized a saliva
based test that is being deployed just
at that site that's expanding their
ability to track what continues to be a
very challenging environment in New
Jersey and Governor Mike Parsons of
Missouri mr. president also told us how
they'd worked with Google Marketplace to
create an online portal for more than
200 companies in Missouri who have
repurposed their manufacturing lines to
create medical supplies to meet their
need within the state and in Connecticut
Governor Ned Lamont spoke about positive
trend lines in Connecticut which has
been really at the center of the
outbreak in the Greater New York area
but he also said they were hoping to
double testing over the next week mr.
president that's just a sampling of what
we heard today and I I know it's an
encouragement to you and I trust it's an
encouragement to people all across the
country
that at your direction we are
implementing a testing strategy that is
supported at the federal level but it is
deployed and managed at the state level
and we want to express our appreciation
to every governor across the country
that are that are standing up all of
those labs that are available that are
working with us and our supply chain
personnel to make sure that the reagents
and the swabs and the equipment is there
to be able to process the tests and
we're going to continue to increase
testing dramatically in the weeks ahead
so we want to thank our governor's for
the progress that we're making on
testing and for their role in in urging
their citizens to practice the kind of
mitigation and social distancing efforts
that are really making real progress
we're one team one mission that's to
save lives and because of of all the
efforts that have been made at the state
level and the strong guidance that's
come from the federal level because of
the amazing health care workers across
this country and our first responders
but mostly I believe because of the
cooperation of millions of Americans who
put the guidance into practice their
cooperation and their prayers have set
us on a path where we are slowing the
spread we are protecting our most
vulnerable and I truly do believe the
day will soon come when we will heal our
land and we'll be able to reopen America
and put this great nation back to work
[Music]